on prime crime he saw someone
yes i thought it was my apartment
oh my god i'm sorry it's a police
shooting
hard to imagine
and i'm so sorry and a defendant who may
not be
what she seems i do believe that she
is re-traumatizing the family
hey everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable true
crime cases
there are a lot of dangers in the world
and our home is always supposed to be
the place where we're safe
but for one young man it proved to be
anything but
good this is carlo where's your
emergency
on september 6 2018 in dallas texas
police officer amber geiger returns back
to her apartment complex
after a 13-hour shift but she doesn't go
to her unit on the third
floor instead she ends up on the fourth
floor
hi this is um off duty officer um can i
get any emails
um i'm in number
um
i thought it was in my apartment and i
shot a guy thinking that he was
thinking it was my apartment geiger
claimed that she mistakenly thought she
entered her apartment
when in reality it was the home of her
26 year old neighbor
botham jean i think there were signs
that uh should have showed her that she
was going to the wrong place
i mean at the outset when she walks up
to the front door there's a red doormat
that is not her own
that should have been a signal not only
that but entering into the apartment
it very much looked like any other
bachelor's apartment or what you would
expect in a bachelor's apartment to look
like
there was an ironing board that was out
there were uh
you know pictures and hangings on the
wall uh that
presumably did not uh look like the
things in her own house
i thought it was my apartment
then there are other subtle signs
so the amount of time that it takes to
navigate from one floor to the other
something usually goes off in your mind
it's taking me a little bit longer
than it normally does and then further
you look at the totality
of the mistakes right it may be all
small things but if it's ten small
things at what point
do you kind of wake up and understand
that you're in the wrong place
investigators would conclude that at the
time geiger entered the unit
jean was on the couch eating ice cream
evidence would even suggest that jon may
have been in a cowering or
ducking position when shot so then why
did geiger shoot him
although she failed to clearly state
this on the 911 call
she later said she thought jean was an
intruder
and her life was in danger i don't
believe that she reasonably perceived
a threat here she entered into an
apartment that was not her own
it didn't have the same doormat
presumably
the affixments and and things on the
walls were not like her own
not only that he was not armed maybe he
spoke in a loud voice but of course
that's because
she was in his apartment concealment and
cover
should come before firing your weapon
when possible
tactically the best thing would have
been to back uh out of the
doorway and try to take cover she had a
radio could have called 911
was this geiger's fault because she was
over tired from a long
shift or because she was distracted
the investigation would show that geiger
had been sexting with her partner and
occasional lover
officer martin rivera sending messages
such as
super horny today and wanna touch
in fact geiger was on the phone with
rivera as she pulled into her apartment
complex
she was certainly distracted but
distracted to a point where you would
enter an apartment that was the wrong
apartment
think that someone's an assailant and
kill them that's quite a leap
not to mention she is an emergency
service worker
that's why we give them so much uh
praise because they are constantly
working
under extreme conditions where they are
a little bit tired a little bit
distracted
but that does not distract them from
doing their job
as geiger excitedly tries to explain
what happened listen carefully to what
she says
he saw someone yes i thought it was my
apartment
oh my god i'm sorry
geiger's 9-1-1 call was very interesting
uh she seemed to be very focused on the
consequence
to her okay we have help on the way i
know but i'm
gonna lose my dog i thought it was my
apartment
i thought it was my apartment i could've
sworn i parked on the third floor
okay i understand no
i thought it was my apartment that was
my apartment
of course she continues to reiterate
that
she thought it was her apartment she
thought it was her apartment i think it
was some 19 times
she talks about uh parking on the wrong
floor which i don't know how she would
know that if she had just shot someone
seemed to me that she was getting
together uh
her excuse uh that she was going to say
to the 9-1-1
operator and whoever else uh to justify
this shooting a boat on john
oh my god i'm done i didn't mean to
i didn't mean to i didn't mean to
i'm so sorry in fairness a
shooting is a life-altering event the
overwhelming majority of police officers
go through 20-25 years of service and
never fire their weapons
and to shoot your weapon and hit someone
and know that that person's probably
going to expire
is a life-altering event so she
certainly did sound a little panicked
on the 9-1-1 calls however
that's somewhat reasonable towards the
end of the 9-1-1 call
we hear officers responding to the crime
scene that's when new pieces of the
story
come into focus i thought they were in
my apartment i thought this was my floor
[Music]
okay and where are you at right now i'm
inside the apartment with him
hey come on what's your name i'm amber
geiger
dallas police officer amber geiger shot
and killed her unarmed neighbor botham
jean inside his home
according to geiger she mistakenly
believed jean was an assailant in her
own apartment
as she's on the phone with 911 dispatch
law enforcement rushed to the scene
officers then race into john's apartment
[Applause]
while the responding officers
desperately tried but ultimately
couldn't save john's life
the audio and video at the time told a
lot about what
amber geiger did or rather didn't do
more than likely she failed to render
aid to baltimore john
it's just plain and simple hey bud
hey buddy
she's not administering any cpr or
anything like that when the officers
arrived there's no blood on her
she hadn't really touched him neither is
she
asking for any advice from the 911
officer
or are discussing what type of medical
aid can be given in order to save his
life
i'm sorry man as a police officer
someone's injured whether it's at your
hand or the hand of another it is your
responsibility to render aid
it's the duty and responsibility of a
police officer to protect the rights
of an individual they are arresting so
how could a trained police officer do
this
when this shooting happened the blame
didn't just rest on geiger
john's family filed a lawsuit against
the city of dallas
which at the time of this taping is
still ongoing
we learned about the ratification of
amber geiger's behavior
by the dallas police department they
provided her training
her equipment they retained her as an
officer
amber geiger was asked a number of
questions
about training she stated uh under oath
that she did not recall her cpr training
she stated under oath
that she did not recall her
de-escalation
training so there were serious training
issues
uh that we think led to the death of
both
amber geiger talked about being
extremely sleepy
uh she talked about the issues of police
officers having to work
excessive overtime hours those are
issues that we believe places the city
of dallas on the hook
so it's very interesting when we look at
the police department
they're not necessarily responsible what
could the police department in and of
itself have done to avoid this situation
not much not much they could require
police officers to leave their firearms
at work
uh most police departments do not do
that because
the reality is we do in many cases want
police officers to be able to take
action
off duty if they see a crime being
committed
the city of dallas has been exposed
enough
to put a significant pressure on them to
want to make this case go away in terms
of the settlement
there would be a lot of explaining to do
but the person we wanted to hear from
the most
was the shooter herself it was the only
option that went through my head
i was at home and like man will you
answer my questions
yes sir
[Music]
amber geiger the former dallas police
officer who shot botham jean to death in
his own apartment
was arrested and ultimately charged with
murder
during her 2019 trial the question for
the jury was whether geiger's mistakes
and actions were criminal
a question that became all the more
complicated when geiger took the stand
why did you shoot andy i was scared he
was going to kill me
amber geiger took the the stand in her
trial and i think that was kind of a
no-brainer
quite often we we don't want defendants
to take the stand in this case she had
to she had to tell
her side the story because the evidence
was overwhelming
i heard moving around inside my
apartment
what type of moving around loud
shuffling someone walking
what did the figure do after you said
let me see your hands
he started coming towards me did you
hear anything as he was walking towards
you
he there was a loud yell he was yelling
hey hey
hey an aggressive voice okay
the defense's case was entirely turned
on
whether her mistake was reasonable if
her mistake was reasonable
then everything that flowed from the
mistake was just simply that a mistake
and it was
excusable why did you fire
so i was scared i was scared this person
said
i was gonna hurt me and i'm so sorry
[Music]
i'm sorry
whether or not this was an accident look
i just can't see it
she went to this house i saw the door
open
the door mat was different the
accoutrements in the house were
different
there was a different person in the
house i i don't see how that is
reasonably perceived as a mistake
i kind of didn't buy him she is a
or was a police officer did somewhat
work against her
what do we think of police officers we
think of those are folks who have some
type of
heightened sense of awareness and where
they are
when the prosecution questioned geiger
they tried to show the jury
just how irrational she acted that night
you should have taken a position of
cover and concealment
and got help and instead you decided to
go
in yes i did go in
you had a police radio on you didn't you
i did
when law enforcement officers encounter
a circumstance
where they might be confronting somebody
in some type of illegal behavior
such as a burglary uh you know
the idea is not for them to rush in
rambo style
and confront a burglar because that puts
them in danger
that they don't necessarily need to be
in then
geiger dropped a bombshell when you pull
that trigger
you intended to kill mr jean
he was the threat yes sir will you
answer my question
when you aimed and pulled the trigger at
mr jean
shooting him in center mass exactly
where you are trained
you intended to kill mr john i did
i literally my hand went over my mouth
when i heard that
i don't think i've ever heard a police
officer testify that they intended to
kill someone
i've heard police officers testify they
haven't they intended to
stop the threat they intended to protect
themselves protect someone else
police officers are not trained to kill
how do you feel like a terrible person
i feel like a piece of crap he hated
everything i
hate and i have to live with this every
single time
i ask god for forgiveness and make hate
myself
every single day she absolutely showed
a high level of remorse it wasn't
remorse just because she was going to go
to jail
this was something that she didn't in an
outcome that she didn't intend
i feel like i don't deserve the chance
to be with my family and friends
i wish he was the one with the gun that
killed me
i never wanted to take an innocent
person's life
and i'm so sorry about geiger's
testimony
for me uh seemed a little bit contrived
she was very focused uh on herself
and uh what was going to happen to her
uh of course there were tears
um that were being shed and you know
it's hard to watch
uh someone hurting but it wasn't
entirely moving for me given the gravity
of the mistake
and the life that she taken we the jury
unanimously find the defendant
amber geiger guilty of murder as charged
in the indictment
no outburst i was surprised by the
verdict
it is very rare that law enforcement
officers
are even charged let alone convicted
i would have to say i was not surprised
by the verdict
i did not hear any reasonable arguments
as to the reasonableness of her mistake
well i think that this case stands for
the proposition that everyone will be
held
accountable it doesn't make any
difference what your profession is or
who you are
we're going to handle it appropriately
and fairly and we think that a dallas
county jury did the same thing
the trial itself was dramatic but what
happened at sentencing
was something entirely unexpected
quite frankly i've never seen anything
like the end of this trial
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father
guilty or not guilty guilty think again
judge caprio rules with common sense i
was having contractions i was rushing to
the hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the circumstances into consideration
the best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before
get caught in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is law and
crime
[Music]
this is not about hate it's about
being scared that night
former dallas police officer amber
geiger was convicted of murdering her
neighbor beatham jean in his own
apartment
after she claimed she accidentally
entered the wrong unit
when it came to sentencing the state
introduced new evidence
the racially charged text message
history of geiger
in one message she arguably pokes fun at
the death of martin luther king jr
and in another criticizes black officers
her text messages reveal that
she's definitely got some issues of bias
or at the very least
some type of insecurity about being
around and or working with black people
the same jury that convicted geiger now
had to determine her sentence
which ranged from five to 99 years in
prison
their decision and assess the
defendant's punishment at 10 years
imprisonment in the texas department of
criminal justice
in addition the sentence in my mind was
a little lenient
the jury took some mercy on her probably
because they felt sympathy
for miss geiger i think this sentence
was
appropriate it goes far beyond
prison her life is changed
if not ruined i think that this is going
to haunt her
we respect the jury's decision we had a
diverse jury from across the county
they heard all of the evidence and they
made their decision based on the facts
of the case and we respect that
but the surprises wouldn't stop there
after the sentencing
john's brother brant took the stand and
in an incredible twist
he asked for the court's permission to
give geiger a hug
quite frankly i've never seen anything
like the end of this trial the
sentencing phase
i was in shock i was in complete shock
i believe that helped them to let them
know that they were forgiving her
because so they would not have to carry
that portion of the pain around with
them
it's just amazing that that young man
could find that amount of forgiveness
and love in his heart
the best qualities of his brother were
showing through him at that moment
then judge tammy kemp followed suit and
not only
hugged geiger but lent her her bible
when i saw that initially the judge
giving uh
miss geiger a hug and the bible i
thought it was a little much
but again maybe the the testimony of
miss geiger
really made a lasting impression on
everyone in that courtroom
i don't think there was any evidence
that showed that she's an inherently bad
person the judge obviously felt that she
was not an evil person and she responded
what i feel was in an appropriate way i
don't have any problems with what the
judge did
at the time of this taping geiger has
appealed her case
arguing she shouldn't have been
convicted of murder rather her legal
team says
she should either receive an acquittal
or a conviction on the lower charge of
criminally negligent homicide
and be re-sentenced i don't see her
being successful at all courts don't
like to overturn jury verdicts
especially in this type of case
when we talk about this criminal
negligence standard it means that there
was something that one
should have known and they didn't know i
don't see how the charge could be
negligence if she herself understands
said she
intended to kill someone it may be a
dangerous slippery slope for her
you know asking to be re-sentenced maybe
she gets re-sentenced to worse
i think the fact that she appeals on
those grounds
that she believes that this should be
the conviction should be thrown out
is evidence that she is not repentant
uh and that she does not really feel
sorry and it
really uh you know draws some question
to
the tears that she said in trial uh i do
believe that she
is re-traumatizing the family who is
trying to move on with this and showed a
lot of grace
and dignity towards ms geiger as if the
mercy
and or the grace that was shown to her
was not good enough
and in some regards it may be a tad
shame
the death of botham jean is as
heartbreaking as it is scary
and there are a lot of takeaways from
this story but when you think about what
happened at the sentencing
a big one for many is you can forgive
but never forget that's all we have for
you here on prime crime
leave us your comments on instagram and
twitter with the hashtag prime crime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you